have to ask you your father on the
Goldbergs is played by Jeff Garlin yeah
and we have a picture of you here I
think with Jeff Garlin yeah and I gotta
ask what's it like working with him
because Jeff and I go way way way way
back we used to live together in an
apartment in Wrigleyville in Chicago
back in my early days when we were both
starting out and he's kind of a madman
I'm curious what's he like on the set
he's a madman yeah yes yeah he likes
well okay this is my first big thing so
I wanted to keep it kind of straight and
it kind of just the show prepared and
kind of do that whole thing it would be
professional all right yeah and but and
Jeff he got me started on showing me
that we're making a comedy and so you
can't really make a comedy if you're
just kind of keeping it serious and just
keeping it so he goes with rule one and
he held it before to his eye and said
I'm in jail and he says like Swedish
nurse and yeah yeah he says random crazy
things all the time as I remember he
used to I'd be fast asleep it would be
3:00 in the morning
he would kick my door open kick my door
open and say it's pudding pop time and I
wake up and I was sleeping on like a
mattress in a windowless room and then
he would say make me do impressions and
skits for him for his amusement and for
some reason I did I didn't say no I just
was like this guy is yelling at me to
perform I better do it so yeah you just
you have that yeah nature yeah it feels
good to be like yeah bond yes you and I
are bonding right that we both spent
time with this absolute madman
this whole lovable man
you